ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show i am tim dillon
what a week we've had little skirmish
over there in the old capitol
stop the ratting stop ratting out all
these idiots that ran into [ __ ]
the capitol they're idiots some of them
did
commit crimes a lot of them didn't they
were just standing there being morons
i told you this sobering up from the q
anon wasn't going to go well
who told you that i said that
i've been on record going they're not
gonna take it well
when they find out that this shit's not
really gonna work out the way they want
it to
imagine you thought you were saving the
children and then you find out you know
you're not
that no one's being saved and you're
wrong
and the people you've invested your
[ __ ]
time into in some cases your money
the people you had faith in have sold
you down the river like trump did when
he went up and
and you know correctly he was like what
the [ __ ]
can't do this after encouraging them and
egging them on
saying they were great people they went
out and went well wait a minute
but this is what happens
this is a a tough pill for those people
to swallow
but you don't need to rat on everybody
in that crowd
come on i didn't even rat on the airbnb
who tried to destroy my life
because we simply wanted to have a meal
in their drug den in joshua tree
i didn't even drop a dime on them
cause i am against ratting
i you know just let it go also why do
you want to do your
someone else's job for them why do you
want to do
someone else's job that's the cops job
let the cops figure out who stole nancy
pelosi's pen
you don't have to go into citizen
detective mode
and figure out who is responsible
i mean for doing whatever the hell they
did
supposedly smearing [ __ ] is that true
yeah yeah they took shits in the
bathrooms and
tracked it all over the capitol building
yeah oh yeah yeah
they're doing what they're accusing the
p the cues accusing the
senators are doing these people like how
do you like him
but you don't have to go out there and
and you know where in the world is
carmen san diego where in the world is
you know i don't know the dude with the
horns or whatever
these people are going to get found out
you don't have to be an online
sleuth these people are going to get
found out the cops are going to arrest
them this is what's going to happen
but it's so funny schizophrenic
everything is like now now everybody
it's like cops are heroes these police
are heroes the capitol police are heroes
you see those cops they're heroes you
see the black cop who's who's all the
white people yelling at him he's a hero
however the black cop where the white
and black mixed race crowd was yelling
at him with the blm protest
that guy's a uh uh part of the problem
but now that guy's a hero
you see so nobody has any values nothing
matters
truly nothing matters no one really
cares the cops are heroes now
and protesting is bad just being out of
protest is bad
and it should bar you from ever being
employed again ever
no one should work ever again you should
lose your job
as an apprentice at the tattoo parlor
these people don't have high level jobs
but they work at like call
centers there's some poor guy
some schmuck who's gotten sucked into a
q anon cult
because he can't afford any other type
of cult
he's [ __ ] you know spends six months
thinks he's hunting pedophiles on 4chan
then he [ __ ] goes to meet up with his
friends all of a sudden he gets
caught up in a moment and he's in the
[ __ ] chamber
of you know congress yeah i mean it's a
bad choice
it's probably gonna [ __ ] him from doing
certain things let that schmuck
if he's charged with a crime he's
charged with a crime whatever
you know if he got caught you got caught
but don't you go and i mean let the guy
go back to the call center job
this isn't the cfo of [ __ ] goldman
sachs running around there
these people's lives are not great
that's why they're there with
a helmet on nobody has a really good
life is in the congress with a helmet on
i'm telling you these people have mental
problems
most of them it's the blm people a lot
of them the hardcore
i'm talking about you know the 300 pound
woman with purple hair
the people that are screaming and going
nuts and
my friend's 80 year old uncle's in a car
and they go up to the car and they're
like say black lives matter
say it the people that are like
harassing the elderly
they have mental problems as well it's
not just like
you have a political difference with
these people they're extremists
that ideology comes from being mentally
unwell
being socially unwell
these are antisocial personality
disorders they should be studied
not listened to not retweeted
they should be studied
but you know i i just can't get involved
with the ratting
these people really thought this
presidency was going to end a different
way and i mean you know unfortunately
i was ringing the bell for that i'm
telling them this is not the way it's
going to work
you know it's like the movie clifford
the great movie clifford storing one of
my favorites charles grodin and then
martin short
clifford with mary steenburgen clifford
was great because clifford wanted to go
to dinosaur world
and uh you know his uncle martin kept uh
running into problems he was unable to
take him to dinosaur world
well and then he of course went insane
and
um his uncle martin was building a model
of the
la transportation system and then
clifford blew it up
sorry spoiler alert spoiler alert
and that is how people reacted when they
found out they couldn't go to dinosaur
world that they weren't going to be
personally arresting barack and michelle
obama
and putting them in guantanamo bay they
thought they were going to be marching
down [ __ ] beverly boulevard and they
were going to go up into the hills to
chrissy teigen's house
and take her out and arrest her and then
i guess steal her cookware line and
cook with it or i don't know but they
really thought this was was going to
happen that alan degeneres was going to
be going to jail
none of this was true all this was
[ __ ] all of this was like
you know a larping [ __ ] just
troll game that these people fell for
because they're terribly unsophisticated
and because the country is so
[ __ ] up and so many of the monsters
are real
that these people found out about it and
their hand their brains melted they had
no idea
when they found out about the epsteins
and the this and that and how [ __ ] up
things are
automatically overnight they started
they got an overflow of information and
they were manipulated by people
like steve bannon and these other people
that didn't give a [ __ ] about them and
just
they thought we're gonna get their votes
and let them believe whatever we want
them to believe and it really
i don't know how many of the people in
the capital were hardcore q people
but i gotta imagine it's a few
i gotta imagine some of them found their
way in there
wasn't the guy that i we just did that
sketch he was the q and on shaman
yeah the q anon shaman he goes i see
different uh
levels of uh you know
that was just pedophiles this is him
this guy yeah yeah there he is
jake and jelly i think his name is or
and you know you got people there with
neo-nazi flags and everything like that
but here's the other thing folks and
this is like an uncomfortable thing
nobody really wants to talk about this
nobody really wants to admit this
you're not going to be able to arrest or
a shame every nazi you're going to have
to deal with certain nazis you know if
you want a tattoo
you might have to deal with the nazi
unknowingly this is what it is you don't
think i
you don't think i have to deal with
hardcore uh
you know anarcho-communists of course
what if i want ice cream in portland
i can't scoop it myself i gotta deal
with one of these militant dykes i don't
care
i don't want them to lose their job i
just walk in i go yeah
punch nazis and rocky road or whatever i
want that day
and this [ __ ] scoops it up and it's we
move on
i don't give a [ __ ] i don't i don't go
oh this [ __ ] wants to destroy
anything good about what i think this
country means
let's get rid of her i don't care that
if she heard my comedy she'd probably
want me in a cage i just moved the [ __ ]
on
get your [ __ ] ice cream and go get
your tattoo and go
why are we gonna arrest everybody people
i don't who cares what people believe
yes if you run into the capitol yes
you're gonna get arrested
it's what it is i mean i don't know what
to tell you
you know if you do something crazy in
the blm protest you burn down somebody's
small business
yeah you're gonna be arrested you're
destroying property like
you know what are you gonna do but if
you're just being an
idiot i don't know what's the punishment
for that
you're probably not doing that great you
know
so i don't know i just i think this is
this i don't know what happened when
everybody's like we gotta get we gotta
get rid of all these
everybody we disagree with they can't
they can't have shitty jobs
people aren't really raking it in here
you know these people aren't doing well
for the most part they're living off
money they've inherited
they they have some type of stipend
they're living in some type of communal
how i don't know what the [ __ ] they're
doing
but i mean i'm sure that i deal
i deal professionally with people i
disagree with all the time about
many different things all the time about
many many different things
you know i i i would never expect
i have a personal trainer who i disagree
with about many things
because he was like he's always like
what are you eating what are you doing
and i'm like
i think it's more important for him to
start looking into cue
and to discover the truth for himself
but he's very like about me
and everything i'm doing and i'm like
that's not that important when you look
at all the children have you saved all
of the children yet
no well then how about you go and state
have you saved any of them
no why well i haven't found the
underground tunnels
anyway what did you have for breakfast
keep looking for the tunnels
there's you see there's we're having a
divergence of opinion we're unable to
serve each other
in in the way that we need to i have
professional disagreement all the time
and i deal with people and i make the
best of it because i'm a [ __ ] adult
i don't care if the dental hygienist
believes in ghosts it doesn't matter to
me if the [ __ ]
cleaning my teeth went to the [ __ ]
area 51 roswell convention
and [ __ ] dressed or dressed like a
gray alien
and jumped around on dmt as long as
she's sober when she's [ __ ] cleaning
my teeth
i don't know what this [ __ ] thinks
about i don't want to know
i don't want to know i got enough
problem thoughts in my own goddamn head
to worry about what other people are
doing okay so all these people that are
just ratting people out
oh you know don't give these people any
of your money a
you know nazi tattoo or whatever it's
like i don't know don't get a tattoo
they're stupid
tattoos are stupid they are
i'm sorry i know many of you have them
and you love them and everyone has one
now
why don't you be the person that doesn't
get one how about you be the badass that
doesn't get a tattoo
and then you won't worry if your money's
not going to yeah let your dead dog or
your dead grandfather
let them lie you don't need them on your
bicep
let them lie okay
i deal with [ __ ] militant communist
dikes
all the [ __ ] time they're in every
ice cream parlor ever
and i loved coffee at one time they were
in all the coffee shops
black black antifa in the coffee shop if
i want a lemon loaf
i gotta deal with black black it is what
it is
and those dykes got a thick loaf and
they make a good espresso
so you just go in and you [ __ ] mix it
up with them you act like they actually
[ __ ] punch nazis [ __ ] trump
yeah you know smashed a patriarchy you
know can i get a scone and
earl grey with honey you know just do
what you got to do
so if you're getting it if you're going
to tattoo with nazi tattoo you get in
there i go hey how are you
all right so anyway just i want to clean
this up
yeah just put 1987 there yeah yeah yeah
that's your my birth all right hi hitler
all right let's do this
just [ __ ] fit in so the whole point
of the country is fit in
we were just in vegas we went to vegas
for two days because nothing's open in
l.a we just wanted to go to dinner
frankly
and vegas has been brought to its knees
by this i mean it is so bad they thank
you for parking your car now
that's how bad it is the valet people
are happy to see you in vegas
they're like hey good to see you thanks
for coming
thanks for coming here i mean you feel
like you're a king i mean you feel like
you're
everybody in vegas right now feels like
a high roller you want to feel like a
high roller go to vegas
now doesn't matter what you're spending
i didn't go near a poker table or a slot
machine the whole time i was there
you will feel like a hot well you know i
i should have but i just i'm not really
a gambler but i can play
cards a little bit if i want to but you
will feel like a high roller they're
just so lucky you'll get in all the best
restaurants you can get in anywhere
it's not a problem and they're happy to
have you just go there
they're happy that the [ __ ] are happy
to have you the the
[ __ ] are happy to suck your [ __ ] in
vegas right now
they are happy to suck i got been a
transgender
african-american uh prostitute your wife
doesn't listen right
they're happy to have you they're so
happy to have they they thank you
idahor trying to pay me
they give you discounts they're happy
you're there
everybody is happy the buffets are
closed which i don't love
because that's part of it part of the
experience but the
[ __ ] are happy doesn't matter if you
have a rash
they don't care if you've showered they
don't care if you're
tested for cove or not doesn't matter
they don't even care if you can stay
hard the whole time they will take your
dick
and they will [ __ ] it they will use
their teeth on that [ __ ]
to get them up and running they are just
happy to
have you they will take your dick and
put it in a thing of hot fudge
and suck it off they're so happy for you
to be there and the valet people are
even happier
you might not even need a [ __ ] the
valet people
are so happy we had a lesbian
who ran the valet which was good because
they're very business-minded the great
thing about lesbians is
they take any job seriously there's a
very it's a respecting for them
whereas gay men unless they're doing the
job there that's their dream
don't really do it well they don't
really like and i always explain it been
like if i
had that job valeting cars the manager
would come to me and go
hi you're not doing this right and
everyone's upset and i would look at him
and go
it's a stupid job though no and he'd be
like
what and i'd be like it's dumb we're
just driving a car into a
i mean it's dumb i'm doing it the best i
can but come on it's horrible
but the lesbians they just [ __ ] hit
it they hit it and they do it well
because they just do it they just like
the simple things about life
it's just easy to you know so uh respect
to that woman we tipped her well give
her 100 bucks for everybody
uh but that that is where vegas is right
now they are so
sad uh it is so depressing
uh it is like the an apocalypse but like
i've never seen
like there's nothing going on you would
think it would be like the real
apocalypse is in the capital it's in dc
vegas is like calm and relaxed just a
couple of lifers
pulling slots a couple of fat old people
not giving a [ __ ] mask under nose just
like
that's the new real gangster move mask
under your nose like say
say something about it [ __ ] throwing up
the margaritas they don't give a [ __ ]
they're just living
they're just living there we had dinner
at carbone which is a big restaurant new
york that's now in vegas
and uh and it was fun not as good as the
one in new york but it was good
and we had dinner at uh what is it
menumi yeah the sushi restaurant in the
wind
very nice we sat outside at the pagoda
table
nice and safe nice and distanced
and it was fun it was just nice to be
out having dinner it was nice to
to be out i mean la shut down and it's
been very hard for me to even
get material to talk about as a comedian
and we made a sketch in vegas it was a
lot of fun
went to a costume shop found that guy's
you know [ __ ] skin cap or whatever and
got horns and whatever but it becomes
difficult to live in a city
and i'm not i get it it's bad out there
hospitals are bad right now in la
but it becomes difficult to live in a
city that is completely shut down
uh there's nothing to do you can't leave
your home really
there's nowhere to go there's nothing to
see and if you're a comedian or you make
your living talking and observing
there's nothing to observe so i went out
to vegas and i was very i was very happy
about that it was good we did a patreon
with ty rivera
uh very funny comedian who lives out
there and um
vegas is open the comedy clubs are
starting to open
but they're open at a very low capacity
so you only got like 40 seats in there
at the comedy clubs in las vegas so
you're not really
you know you're not you're not making
money there yet
uh but it's opening little by little
little by little what was your
impression you haven't been a lot but i
mean
this was pretty bleak you said it best
it's been brought to its knees the
homelessness looked real rough
real rough in a lot of parts of the city
it's not as bad as la though
and it's open but no one's there you
know it's open but nobody's there
the casinos are allowed a minimal
capacity of where they used to be i
don't know what it is someone could fill
me in on
on on the actual capacity um
the homelessness problem is not as
striking as la
for whatever reason you don't but it is
bad i mean this is it's it's not good
you know
so this is as of november 29 2020 new
restrictions
limit capacity of casinos and
restaurants
restaurants can see patrons if they have
reservations and no more than four
diners or a lab for table masks are
acquired at all times
indoors and out maximum size of public
gatherings
is 50 people yeah which will crush the
recent revival of live entertainment
so that's where you're at uh a lot of
casinos are not opening weekdays
they are opening uh thursday through
monday
and some of them are just not functional
during the week it doesn't make sense
for them to open
so little by little las vegas turning
around one of my favorite cities i do
like las vegas couldn't ever live there
but like going there for 48 hours at a
time
checking up on vegas and seeing what is
uh going on i just couldn't live there
it's one of those places i don't
think i could live
there's a certain type of person that
can and i respect that person that's
just not me
same with new orleans that i love new
orleans i couldn't live there
it's just too much even though i like it
i just couldn't do it
the special thing it's like the way a
lot of people feel about new york and
now i kind of feel about new york i
couldn't
live there you know every new year all
you hear is new year new me that usually
means you'll be picking up better habits
of trying new things okay
if you do take up a new hobby it's even
better when you have amazing audio that
will make the experience even better
that's why i recommend wireless earbuds
from raycon
okay it's like apple but better i'm
telling you right now you need them
they're cheaper they're better
you get six hours of play time they're
accessible to everybody
wireless earbuds start at half the price
of other premium audio brands
okay you don't have those dangling wires
hanging out of your ears you put them in
your ears they're great
it's a great way to support our show
they perform whether you take them
wherever you take them six hours water
sweat resistant construction doesn't
matter
bluetooth it pairs quickly and
seamlessly okay
i i have raycons i don't know why you
don't have them
they're great backup pair of headphones
if you lose the pair you have they're a
great primary pair of headphones
you could just have them they're
offering 15 of all their products from
my listeners
and here's what you got to do to get it
go to buy raycon dot com tim
that's it 15 off your entire raid con
order it's a great gift
for somebody belated christmas birthday
gift 15
off by raycon.com tim go here
here's some headphones back a pair of
headphones for you it's nice it's a
thoughtful gift
shows you're a thoughtful person okay so
buy raycon.com
you'll get raycon earbuds waterproof six
hours of play time
great experience you'll love it whoever
you're giving them to is gonna love it
thank you
what up q anon shaman is there something
interfering with your happiness
or preventing you from achieving your
goals better help will assess your needs
and
better help is back better help will
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours it is not a crisis line it is not
self-help
it is a professional counseling done
securely online there is a broad range
of expertise available which may not be
locally available in many areas
especially now with the pandemic you get
online you get the help
the service is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
or video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy better help is
committed
to facilitating great therapeutic
matches so they make it easy and free to
change counselors if needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available
better help wants you to start living a
happier life today
visit their website read their
testimonials that are posted daily
go to betterhelp.com tim d that's better
help better help better hlp
and join the over one million people
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using better help they're
recruiting additional counselors in all
50 states
betterhelp.com tim d
you get 10 off your first month it is
great
so the capital uh skirmish uh
who's our boy what's his name we just
did the video about the q and on shaman
the q anon shaman are they trying to put
him in the clink
for this behavior i believe they
arrested him already yeah
i mean he was pretty out there in the
open wasn't he yeah yeah yeah
yeah jake and jelly lead siege of
catholics by the way this wasn't a coup
everyone's saying this was a coup
or a revolution i mean this was closer
to a high school theater group i mean
listen
they they were not they i mean i'm not
excusing what they did right
what they did was [ __ ] insane and
obviously there were laws that they
broke
and they will go to jail like and and by
the way that's everybody that destroys
property
break breaking and entering these are
all laws that we have
for a reason civil society exists for a
reason okay
so if you're breaking those laws uh for
whatever because you
think that you know uh the landlord
should all be taken out and hung
that's that's breaking a law and if you
break the law because you think that
inside of uh congress there's a chamber
with children that nancy pelosi is
eating
you're breaking a law either way you're
breaking a law
so you know sorry to everybody who's
like but i like one kind of riot
that's the maturity of this country
everybody's sitting behind screens being
like
well this violent protest was not good
i like that kind i like this type of
chaos it's like people sitting in a
restaurant being like i enjoy this type
of chaos
oh you like that chaos i like this chaos
ah interesting just people tasting wine
a sommelier comes over the sommelier of
like you know
the apocalypse and he's like what do you
like
what do you like do you like a racial
equity narrative
with some burned buildings and some
chase please or would you like a
proto-fascist takeover
involving a horned gentleman leading a
group of people
up the steps of congress and people like
hmm they both
sound appealing
it's stupid you cannot encourage this
type of behavior
at all very funny though you know it's
funny
q anon shaman known as 33 year old jake
angeli of phoenix man
phoenix huh has been a fixture at a
number of pro-trump rallies and protests
across
2020 especially in his home state soon
after q anon shaman received viral
infamy
some followers of the loose collective
of conspiracy theorists
movement began to turn on him falsely
suggesting angeli is actually antifa
and had infiltrated the mob ain't that
always the way
man what a short rise right
ain't that always the way
it's like this it's like i'm in the
movement i'm in the movement queuing on
queueing on queueing on
viral viral big antifa
a big circle it's almost like the people
that get involved in these things aren't
the most
stable and they'll actually turn on
anyone
interesting it's like the underpinnings
of these movements are not
logical coherent political beliefs uh
it's really
the majority of it is undiagnosed and
diagnosed
mental illness many of these people have
been diagnosed by the way
i wanted to correct uh kansas owens when
she said it's undiagnosed mental illness
i'm like many of it a lot of it's
diagnosed
somebody tweets why aren't these quote
crisis actors more successful in acting
this guy was way into the wrong much
earlier clearly a method actor he's
really selling it
he should be alongside de niro is this
the one where he's yelling let's see
what this is this is a crazy conspiracy
theorist he also people getting covetes
in arizona i think this is our boy jake
angeli all right
it's [ __ ] crazy you guys the amount
of people that believe this [ __ ]
is insane interesting this just goes to
show the mockingbird media
the way it uses fear to compartmentalize
to propagandize and divide and conquer
our country this whole country is an
episode of the x-files
i mean look at this look at this bush
[Applause]
the virus survive
arizona's heat by the way stop this
i know like 30 comics that are that are
five minutes away from this behavior
if they don't get it special i know 30
to 50 people that are five minutes away
from horns
and screaming in a parking lot if
something doesn't turn around if you
don't let them go perform
somewhere
this is a scientific fact
the corrupt media is lying to you
your corrupt governments
dick ducey is [ __ ] led to you
grove in 1984
is a globalist propaganda hoax
i love all the people that are like
colvin's the global at the big global
reset
it's like what reset it's been going the
way it's been going
for 50 years what reason there's no
reset it's this
i'll tell you this no more i can't tell
he's just talking it's annoying
with the it's annoying
um but yeah that's jake and jelly
i mean these these people again you know
i don't i've never known someone
you know i i guess i've i've witnessed
people that have gone really radical
in their belief systems uh not quite to
that extent where it's like costume
shop radical but i've known people that
have gone really off the reservation
and the one thing that seems to unite
all of them is that number one they
started to get attention
doing it it was what got them attention
so they would never stop because it was
the only way they got attention they
didn't get attention other ways
they weren't they didn't get attention
from their talent and they didn't get
attention
uh from uh you know any you know
interpersonal thing
that was good going on in their life
they got a tension
by going crazy
publicly in front of people you know
this is what
they you know enjoy doing and i don't
mean and i don't just mean whitney but
there are people
kidding she's her dog she called me her
dog ate her hand or something it's fine
but i've i've seen people politically go
off the radar go off the rails like this
and they're off the reservation
i know that's not a kosher term to say
but this is what happens they
you know you know you're yelling in a
parking lot
with a [ __ ] with viking horns on
you're not
it's not going well so i don't know what
this got but this guy's gonna see some
real
jail time probably you know probably i
mean this is a real embarrassing end for
the q movement
i thought it would kind of silently kind
of
just go away like like a tide goes out
like a tide comes in and the tide goes
out
this one was rough this one was a little
embarrassing
for the q movement this was rough i
don't know what the hell they thought
was gonna happen they were gonna get in
there and the u.s military was gonna go
you're right
let's go and then jake angeli is the
president yeah what did you think
it's the same thing with a black lives
matter it's like what did you think was
going to happen
just the national guard's going to stand
down you're going to take over portland
i mean i don't know but now of course we
have
uh you know the the this very
schizophrenic
body politic where you can't keep up
with
everything you can't even understand
you're like okay
you're like these people gathered in
front of government buildings and they
harass
the police who are heroes
[Laughter]
and you're like staring at these people
like what
wait a minute what and then they find
all the black lives matter protests that
were always peaceful like nothing yes
like because we all know the riots we
were watching had nothing to do
with the protest i mean they had nothing
to do with that and they didn't happen
most of the riots didn't have that you
saw with your own eyes the burning of
businesses the burning of cop cars the
looting of stores
that didn't happen and if it did happen
it was justified
that didn't happen you saw it i i
brought it up i
people are angry at me because i've
literally people
hate me because i've literally said
things i've seen with my eyes
[Laughter]
that has label people are angry with me
because
i'm a chill and right-wing and alt-right
or whatever
because i've just uh i've been sitting
in front of a tv and
huh okay i'm seeing a thing
and now i'm saying what i'm seeing and
people have gotten angry about that you
know
getting angry i get it i have enemies
people dislike me because i've literally
just said what i've seen
so when you say what you've seen uh
people get angry there were some people
uh
that were uh knuckleheads in all these
movements that seem to just want to
you know benefit themselves in in you
know do crazy things these are like
people
these were like dorks and i'm not again
um people are gonna be like they're
terrorists sure
sure but also let's not glorify them
uh by by making them out to be more than
what they are
they were willing to do some very stupid
things which they'll pay for
but they're idiots i mean they're not
the terrorists are always smart but like
these people believe in a fairy tale
they're door i mean
some of them are like elderly you see
that old woman
you see the photo of her i'm gonna
compare her to like a like a terrorist
to like
the woman's got dementia she's wandering
around the capitol
she doesn't even know what's going on
you know what i mean
this is a crazy woman whose prescription
medication is
all messed up and she's
she's wandering around the capitol
the woman that got mace too yeah yeah
you know i mean and then there's a woman
that got amazed
let's play her she's like i love how
nonchalantly she goes it's a revolution
they're like what are you doing here she
goes uh it's a revolution
tummy what do you think i'm doing
here we go ma'am fun
what happened to you fun couple alert i
got names
by the police you know by the way stop
that and what happened
she was getting amazed and her man was
like
that's you know he's kind of unbothered
he's he's completely unaffected she's
just got mace in the face
he's you know in the ride home he looks
at her and goes you got a little excited
he got a little excited and she goes
well it was a revolution
i know i know i know but you got a
little excited and she's like they
didn't mace you and he goes why
you know you went nuts you went you
tried to jump on that cop's back
she goes well it was a coup it was a
revolution you don't like anything i do
you never support me
if this woman could get a small business
loan to be a caterer would she be doing
this
yeah i made it like a foot inside and
they pushed me out
and they amazed me what's your name
what's your name where are you from my
name is elizabeth i'm from knoxville
tennessee
and why did you want to go in we're
storming the capitol it's a revolution
we're storming the capital it's a
revolution
dummy are you dumb
we're storming the capitals but these
people just want to have fun i mean i
think it's time we open up dave and
busters we've gone too long
this didn't work this whole experiment
where americans didn't work
doesn't work let's take note
this doesn't seem to produce good
results
okay so i don't care what the next thing
is i don't care if it's the black plague
i don't care if it's ebola hemorrhagic
fever
bleeding through the eyes when you close
down
fuddruckers and dave and busters and
applebees and fridays and two for one
margarita night at chili's
it ends a few months later with a guy in
horns
standing in the middle of the capital
that's where it ends
so think long and hard about that gavin
newsom think long and hard about where
this is going to end
it's really crazy but the country is not
built
to do anything except work sadly it's
just what we're built to do
it's what we're built to do we are built
to just run at 100 miles an hour and
work and work and work and if we don't
do it it becomes a real problem and then
you get this and then you get this woman
who's
looks like kind of a normal suburban
lady kind of yeah
and i'm not saying that because she's
white i'm saying that because she
doesn't have blue hair and
face tattoos and nose rings she looks
kind of like whatever
i mean she's got a piano scarf is that a
piano scarf maybe not i'm
straight no it's just striped uh i don't
love that but
this this looks like someone's
substitute teacher and she's getting
maced while she runs into the capital i
mean wow
you got to hand it to trump though he
knows how to sell a product he really
does
i mean you know he knows how to
celebrate you know he's walking around
looking at the tv
ah going like because i spoke to
somebody who made a good point
um and they were like they were like
yeah he's just walking around going good
good
this is good very happy oh yeah because
he wants he wants people to know that he
can
he could [ __ ] he could cause little
ruckus and he's not going to be a
binding inauguration
he's going to be out of there let's play
our video which is very funny please
of course if you have not seen this uh
you should see this this is an interview
with
uh jake and jelly and we get to the
bottom of
of what jake and jelly's really all
about
i'm sorry things got out of hand okay
does everything people are saying about
me isn't true i'm an actor
i'm a voice actor i'm a musician stop
the steel
what people saw yesterday was me doing
vocal exercises
me just kind of you know putting myself
out there for the first time
the industry just doesn't want a white
male unless they're literally storming
the capital you know
obviously save the children and and do a
coup
but also you know as important or even
more important
is to just try to like you know build my
socials this is my american idol this is
my the voice
i think there is a hole in the market
for sort of this like reactionary
psychopath that's also very musical when
i first started working with q i thought
q mac quincy jones
people said to me what was yesterday was
it a revolution was it a coup
uh it was an exercise in branding we
have no problem
with the capitol police by the way we
have no problem they were nice to us we
took selfies with them they let us in
uh you know we met a lot of them on
4chan sometimes i'm
sad and i feel like
there's not a space for men to share
their feelings
in this country and i think that's
tragic
i'm willing to learn and grow i've been
reading a lot of tweets about my
behavior
that are making a lot of sense to me and
i'm going like back in my childhood and
i'm going
yeah yeah that was it yeah that was it
it's okay if i like the show shrill
on hulu it's my favorite show and i can
admit that like i like it because it's a
big
powerful woman that's confident and that
makes me happy
i'm the victim yeah ridiculous by the
way everyone's like how did you get the
costume so how did you get the costume
so quickly ben avery went to the costume
shop ben avery
really whipped that up shout out to
jones fabric yeah
combination of everything joanne's
fabric what'd i say
jones oh my bad
we'll now do it the right way joanne's
shout out to joanne's fabric in vegas is
[ __ ]
he acts like a petulant child now he
won't do it he's like
yeah um uh
what about uh the costume shop oh yes it
was uh we're gonna shout out this
costume shine this guy just because
they're it's like better than anything
in l.a they're
really cool uh star costume and
theatrical supply star
costume and theatrical supply if you go
in there tell them tim dillon
saying yeah maybe we'll get some some
something off next one we probably won't
we didn't even uh we didn't even
we didn't even uh watch him call it we
didn't like uh we didn't go over
anything with them we should get a deal
yeah we should get a deal if i stairco
if people are going in there
yeah that's an ad this is an ad this is
an ad yeah can we
can we bully companies to pass
retroactively if i say a nice thing
about them on the show
like we do we do reads and then charge
them without ever approving anything i
mean can we call the win
and go hey this guy just talked about
your valet the the lesbian of the valet
thing
said how good she was can we get a
couple of dollars here can we get some
money
i gotta i go to valley my car
let me tell you right now i go to i go
to valet in my car
they get
hey you mean i can't believe this they
put a black guy in the car
i mean i'm like hey buddy if i wanted my
car stolen
i would have [ __ ] put it on blocks
myself sebastian
sebastian we appreciate you coming in
but we're this you're reading a
children's book you're reading a
children's book
and and and and you've just said some
very racist things into the mic and i
want you to kind of
focus right now because it seems very
strange
all right all right i don't even
all right all right sorry all right
there's your busy miner but can i tell
you one thing
can i just tell you one thing i got a tj
maxx
they got one of these asians you don't
even
have you ever seen asian but they look
kind of like a native american
it's like this weird it's like all kinds
are wrong
you know what are you doing what's wrong
with your face
i don't know what to do with these
people do i go like this
or do i like in a spicy tuna roll i
don't know
sebastian we're gonna have to that is a
fantasy that's a character i do where
um sebastian menescalca a brilliant
comedian who i really respect
uh says crazy things yeah
uh he they they bring him in to read a
children's book
and he just says he's like let me tell
you i gotta get something off my channel
and my father was a nazi his american
nazi party my father
and he started explaining to me what
they believe
i have my father he started explaining
to me
about uh what the nazis believe i got to
be honest
uh it's pretty i mean come on it's
pretty accurate i think i'm a nut
so we think that's we think that's
really funny
um and now obviously that's a joke and
i've never spoken to him in real life
but he said nice things about me i
believe to people that have
relayed them to me but we have a lot of
respect for sebastian and we're not
insinuating that he or his family
is in the american nazi party but it is
very funny to do that little there's no
there's no more fun voice to do i just
don't i mean you know what are you gonna
do
it's so entertaining i i just can't stop
i just but i will stop i will stop and i
imagine lawyers will
get involved eventually and
tell me to stop you know it's uh
we're working on a steak sauce we're
developing a steak sauce for people
uh we're gonna launch that in a few
months we're trying to steal
a steak sauce recipe from a restaurant
there i
really want to i i i
the what is the way i've always wanted
to have a sauce
a steak sauce and i want it i
i'm not gonna take it from a place but
i do like i've gone to restaurants where
i go this is a good steak sauce
do you know what i'm saying here like
what's the problem yeah
are you selling your steak sauce no so
then why am i not
you're inspired i'm inspired by it
i'm inspired by it and it's going to be
very good we're developing it we're
working with a chef
we'll try to do our steak sauce and uh
and and then sell it and bring it bring
it to market
so that we can you know you know we
don't have to like worry about these
other companies telling us what to do
and say
you know freedom of speech that's right
steak sauce freedom speech i just like
to say things that will make the people
that hate me hate me so much more
and by connecting steak sauce to freedom
of speech which
you know is absurd uh the people that
whose job it is to hate me all day which
is by the way
good gig good gig um
well people just don't like you there
are people that
it's like it's like the q a thing it's
the same with comedians it's like
everybody starts off going like i'm
gonna be a comedian and then that's q
and i people like we're gonna
save the kids and trump's gonna be the
king and then none of that happens and
then everyone's angry
at me people started out trying to be
comedians can't scratch two nickels
together
can't get a following to have no
audience and it's my fault
how is it my fault they've been doing
this
longer than i have but years and years
and somehow it's i've done it to you
what or or or other people
other successful podcasters or people
we've all we're the problem
we're the issue and they all cloak
themselves in politics and they're like
i just
i could never i could never stoop to the
level
that you've stooped to the people you've
spoken to
okay congratu congratulations
congratulations
i hope has has that gotten you anywhere
has your refusal to talk to anyone
gotten you anywhere
still no still no so you've refused to
speak to anyone and you haven't stooped
and still nothing
i'd start stooping i'd stoop
as low as humanly possible you roach
it's just there's a lot of people
there's business right so i understand
they'll q and i think i understand when
everything you believe
doesn't work out and it doesn't work out
because you were stupid to have believed
it in the first place
that's why it doesn't work dummies
and then you can't get that angry at
yourself because what happens you go to
the holidays and you go like this with
the gun in your mouth
mummy you can't get that mad at yourself
so you have to dole out your hatred in
little bits
little bits and it's got to be i'm a
problem and it's
rogan or it's this guy or that guy and i
hate him
first of all you broke [ __ ] if anyone
had asked you to sit next alex jones not
you would have sat next alex jones in
all of you would have in a minute by the
way
why because no one is asking to do
anything with anybody
so stop getting angry at me this isn't
even a specific person it's just
there's people out there it's just i
just don't understand like
how embarrassing is it you're living in
the heyday
of leftist not really leftist but more
liberal non-comedy you're living that
heyday if you couldn't make a buck
sucking now you'll never make a buck
you didn't even have to be funny you
just had to go
[ __ ] show up at stephen colbert's
office
and and [ __ ] i don't even know
claim to be an eskimo on your mother's
side and write
nine horrible monologue jokes and you
got 3 500 a week
if you didn't make a living sucking
because i know you hate podcasts you
hate all of us because we make a living
like being funny
with our fans it you know it's it's cool
it's a
it's fun for the most part it's some of
it's not
um but if you couldn't if you couldn't
get a writing gig
and then all these woke people you know
what they all say to you
they all tweet about how horrible
podcasting is
all for it's right-wing fascist
and then you know what happens when you
go hey man you got a writing job they go
no i'm white
i'm a white guy can't get a writing job
what you sound like the right-wing guy
i'm not complaining about not writing on
you know
boko haram's new show or whoever they're
giving a show to
on [ __ ] cartoon network i don't give
a [ __ ] the funniest new comedian
boko haram like whoever i i mean no one
cares
no one cares or or whatever whatever
terrorist group
sounds eerily like the name
of a comedian you know i'm a fan like
you know
i'm not mad that i didn't get the
netflix special they gave to ansar al
islam
doesn't matter to me
doesn't matter to me i like antarel
islam
some of the bits are good you go that's
good
but it's just so funny all these people
then they turn around and they say well
i'm white i can't get
i i can't get in the writers room and
i'm like okay
i'm like but yet all you do you know
how's the how's the non-stop
capitulating
and and to self-flagellation and
disgracing yourself
and throwing yourself at the altar of
those that would seek to impoverish and
destroy you
how's that working how has it worked
how has it worked doing nothing with
throwing yourself at the altar of the p
the same people that want you to be
homeless
and to being like they're so good
they're so
funny you're so good has everyone seen
this new show it's so
good
grow up you're too old all of you you're
too old
you're old you're elderly your credits
are like network television
your people are trotting out like the
drew carrich i mean it's a horror
what were you people on empty nest
enough
zh1 chat shows i mean a sahara here
it's crazy let it go go to a farm
go away christ almighty with these
people
you can't make a dollar in comedy now
you don't even have to be good
if you're a woman and you don't own four
houses as a comedian right now
kill yourself
you dumb [ __ ] you should own
nine houses
if you are a minority and haven't gotten
a set on conan
hang it up hang it
up okay
and if you're a funny white guy and you
can't scratch together a couple foul on
a patreon to pay the rent
you ain't a funny white guy clean it up
get it out enough with the whining
if you are a funny white guy that's
being ignored by the business
and you can't scratch up a couple of g's
on patreon you can't scratch up a few
friends then it's time to put the horns
on and go to the capitol
because you're living in a gold rush
of [ __ ] everything they make is [ __ ]
so now you can do something good shane
gillis is doing it
nick mullen's doing it i'm doing it
other people are doing it
do it ryan long makes sketches every
he's doing it andrew schultz is doing it
there are people doing it
just shut up and do it who cares or
don't
or do it for your people do it for your
fans that whatever they want
you know i remember when i got to la
people like yeah well yeah you got in
with the rogan crew but i'm not really
in with those guys cause i'm not an
ultimate fighter where do you think i
met joe at a fighting gym
you dummies i'm a fat [ __ ] you just
suck
you're not good who told you you were
good
sue them sue them the people that told
you you were good at this
me sue them you should be knocking on
their door going
what the [ __ ] you told me that was good
well you're ki you are good a little i
don't know what happened
they're like yo i'm not in an mma so i'm
not here with those guys i've never said
anything
to joe rogan about mma
ever ever we've never had one cover i
said what do you think's gonna happen
with the jake
uh paul fight and i asked him once
if uh one of the hulking lesbians at the
frozen yogurt shop was amanda nunez he
said no
that was it i i have no interest i don't
give a [ __ ]
it's whining all the time everybody
everybody's so
some i'm too good at my job to make
money mullen had that great point
where he's like that people are like too
funny to be funny
they're too good at their job to make
money what
this is if you're like in the industry
it's like this is like the golden era of
sucking at comedy if you can't make
money now
god forbid god forbid it goes back to a
point when like the minimum amount of
talent's required
then you're really [ __ ] all you have
to do right now is kind of show up
look decent talk about how much kamala
harris
has made you feel energized about the
future of the country
i mean stephen colbert kimmel they're
all crying they're all
crying you'll never leave the spend time
none of those people will ever be
respected ever again
none of them they've all destroyed their
legacies destroyed and they were very
funny
they've destroyed their legacies by
being mouthpieces
of a political and getting out and
crying and being unfunny
and being absurd they're forever not
funny anymore you will never see them
and they don't care what they do maybe
they
maybe they donate a lot of money to
breast cancer good for them but
they will never be funny ever again ever
ever ever again so that will never be
funny again
unless they reverse course hire nick
mullen shane gillis
me and candace owens and unless they do
that and i don't see that happening but
if they don't do that they're [ __ ]
forever
sorry if you don't let candace owens
host
and have me shane and nick then you're
not then it's not going to be funny
and higher the leftist red scare and
the period or whatever these you know my
period and
karl marx or whoever these [ __ ] you
know uh
uh you know uh sardonic [ __ ] are that
are pretty funny actually
bring them in too who cares but if it's
just the same
[ __ ] northeastern liberal arts school
concert like
being fat is my oh shut up like it's
over it is over this pandemic killed
those shows
it's killed us in that it's killed all
that but it's opened the space up
for other people to do [ __ ] so just stop
[ __ ] whining stop [ __ ] wanting i
have so much more respect for that [ __ ]
that got made to the capitol
then i do these dumb people that just
sit there and [ __ ] whine just do
something just do something i don't care
what it is it doesn't matter
doesn't matter what it is to me or
anything i don't care what the [ __ ] you
do that's why i don't rat on people i
don't know what people are going through
i don't rat i don't call people up and
say
hey you should be in trouble storming
the cat i don't know why those month
those [ __ ] stormed the capital
capitol though there were kids inside i
mean i don't know
they had to find out there weren't the
old-fashioned way okay
and the black lives matter people are
burning down bodegas and i don't really
love that but i don't you know i've had
some real attitude
from some of the koreans in a bodega
real attitude and i'm not even black
they get a lot worse
so i don't really get involved
you see i don't rap people out i don't
get involved stop getting involved
cut your friend group in in in don't cut
it in half cut it in nothing
strip it up get them all out of your
life
go down to vegas they're happy to have
you the [ __ ] are happy to have you the
restaurants are happy to have you
they're happy if you park your car you
can just go to vegas
play a few hands lose then go back up to
the hotel room order the chocolate cake
we almost vomited it was horrible
it was like the display cake they gave
us it was very bad but
but it's enough with the who cares
and i again i know that it's not
applicable to many people
it's just my own twitter timeline it's
my but this is my own show and i whine
about the [ __ ] that i whine about
so it's my own timeline of people that
just it's just exhausting
what and they're getting old these are
people in their 40s and
50s that are old and they're complaining
and it's like guys
it's not cute anymore it's not
cute no one believes everyone
that's uh leapfrogged you and this is a
nazi
how how [ __ ] lucky for you
huh how coincidental imagine they're
like telling their
children which they won't have they're
like well i was on a great path in
comedy but then comedy was taken over by
nazis and the kid would be like well
what do you mean
actually it seems like mainstream comedy
is just full of people that
believed all the things you believed
so what did you do did you spend all day
smoking weed and drinking
water you don't understand i was dealing
with my
mental health and i had anxiety and
depression i was manic depressive i had
you know i had multiple personalities
and none of them were funny
none of them so that's all i'm saying
i'm saying that we're trying we're
developing a steak sauce
it's going to be very good it'll be the
greatest sauce
that has ever touched a steak and we're
we're we're
we're uh we're doing all we can here
we're meeting with
chefs and food developers and i want to
get into the food business i really want
to own i just want to open a restaurant
and be done with this i i hope that
hurray time horizon for that is ten
years
five to ten years i just want to own a
restaurant
and then blow my brains out on opening
night in front of everyone once it's
once everybody's there and everything's
nice and everyone goes this is really
good i just get in the middle of the
room like bud dwyer and go
good night just to see like
blood all over ben and his wife's face
as they said they'll have made enough
money that so they won't care and they
they just sit there eating unaffected
yeah
having their basic [ __ ] conversations
about nonsense
about god only knows what they talk
about when i'm dead they
can't talk about killing me talk about
the length of grass on someone's lawn
you know you know
blue chew it helps your pp get hard
sex great sex bluetooth brings you the
first trouble with the same fda approved
ingredients as viagra and cialis it is
made in the usa it's prescribed online
by licensed physicians
so you don't have to go to the doctor or
wait in line it's even cheaper than a
pharmacy and they prepare
and ship it right to you in a discrete
package no awkwardness and you don't
need to leave the house i'm telling you
right now
bluee2.com c-h-e-u
all you pay is five dollars shipping
it's great everybody loves it it can
increase your performance and get that
extra confidence in bed
bluetooth.color bluechew.com blue like
the color blue
it is phenomenal you're going to love it
your partner is going to love it
it is very very it's got the same active
ingredients as the ones that cost a lot
more money
that you really need to go get
prescribed and you got to go pick up at
a pharmacy it's very embarrassing
this one is great you're in and out
you're not in or out really you're just
online it comes to your house do you
open the box up
and it is nice i'm telling you you're
gonna love it
b-l-u-e true.com it's a great way to
support
your penis and this show bluetooth.com
promo code td this winter as you get
back into the swing of things bespoke
post this brand new box of awesome
collection for guys
it's a really cool thing they sent me
one of these things i didn't know how
cool it was gonna be
it's really cool whether it's gear to
upgrade your autumn craft beers or cozy
threads when the temperature dips
bespoke post
only sends guys the best of every month
no matter what you're into
box of awesome as you covered from style
and grooming goods
bar wear cooking tools and outdoor gear
box of awesome has collections for every
part of your life
to get started take the quiz at box of
awesome.com they'll figure out what
you're into
okay they will lose release new boxes
every month
across a ton of different categories
each box is about 45
only but it's got 70 worth of gear
inside it's really cool stuff
it's a great way to get a cool box get
off your first monthly box if you're
like me you love getting things in the
mail opening them up and having new [ __ ]
i love that i love cool stuff i like to
be a little surprised don't know what's
coming
box of awesome you give them some
guidelines they know what you're into
broadly speaking
and they give you really cool stuff and
you're into it and you use it
so if you go to box of awesome.com get
20 off your first monthly box when you
sign up
box of awesome.com and enter the code
tim dillon at checkout
that's box of awesome dot com code tim
dillon for 20
off your first box you will not regret
it bespoke post is
really uh uh on the cutting edge here
of the way people are gonna buy things
where it's like i'm gonna tell you
broadly what i like
and you're gonna give me stuff and i'm
gonna really dig it and i'm gonna keep
re-upping you can keep re-upping with
them you don't have to
but it's it's great if you love one box
you're like i want to see the next box
what are they going to throw me in the
spring little things could be personal
hygiene grooming
things for your house things for your
apartment it's great if you're a younger
guy
you're in college you're just out of
college you have a little apartment
you want to do some things to it so
again it's box of awesome.com use code
tim dillon for 20
off your first box but i'll tell you
this folks i'm just i'm just saying
god love you out there don't rat you
lose this part of your soul
everybody needs to figure things out on
their own yes it seems a bit extreme to
storm into the capital to find out
things aren't exactly the way you think
but who am i to judge you're probably
going to do a few years in the clink for
that
probably do a few years of slammer and
you know our criminal justice system
isn't really
rehabilitative you know so you'll
probably come out much worse it's
probably destroyed your entire life
you won't be able to get jobs and it'll
be a [ __ ] nightmare all because you
believed in some horse [ __ ] and you ran
into the capital so
stop that [ __ ] stop it
it's bad for you in terms of like it's
long
term and net negative to get get to get
worked up enough to go storm the capital
i mean listen but i'm i'm i'm not
getting you in trouble
i'm not trying to get you fired from the
call center
i think you should you can still heat up
somebody's soup at panera
i don't care i'm gonna tell you you
can't put together an asiago turkey club
at panera because you're a nazi
you're a nazi you make sandwiches in the
suburbs
it's kind of what you should do it's not
exactly a win
huh what am i gonna do what are we gonna
force all these people
into more desperate situations how's
that gonna work out
has anyone played that out in their head
we're gonna fire all these people
and then force them into more desperate
situations
what could be worse what could be worse
than than than storming the capital with
horns on the top of your head yes
my career like the people that i know
comics they're much worse
but at the end of the day
you know they also they don't have any
balls to storm the capital you know they
can't even
even storm the [ __ ] out their own
door but
you know it's bad enough for half of
these people
you know it's just it's it's so crazy
to think about to think about
how this all ended and how it all came
apart
you know it was bad for a while
and then it got it got worse it started
it started coming apart
it's it's just you know it's completely
it it's unr it's an unraveling it's an
unraveling that's been unraveling it's
just
unraveled now it might get better maybe
now people start to go okay
let's just let's chill out you know what
i mean
let's relax let's build let's build
again let's build a time because
you know spurts of crazy are fun a
prolonged period of insanity nobody
likes that
so let's go back to something boring for
a little bit
let's go back to something boring and
then we can turn up the crazy again
just for fun but don't don't rat anybody
out please
don't be that person don't be the person
that [ __ ]
informs on your fellow citizens no
matter how misguided they may be don't
don't be a
don't inform for the state don't turn
states right don't be a
[ __ ] narc on your fellow crate i
would never i would
never narc on any of these
antifa super soldiers
dykes in portland that own all the ice
cream shops
i would never knock on them i would
never narc i just walk in
i i stare at them silently
i say hello their name is like i don't
know
some genderless one syllable
insane thing makes no sense like
star with three r's and like a chinese
symbol or something i'm like hello
i'm like the [ __ ] fascism in this
country is out of control and she's like
i think they know i'm undercover they
kind of know
she's like yeah and i'm like all right
well
the white chocolate and you know
a little rocky road and a little whipped
cream on that thank you
she gives it to me i go eat it and then
she goes you know back to you know i
don't know beating up andy no
i don't know not my problem
stop making everything your problem you
know and
and just move the [ __ ] on but you know
it's fun being out there in vegas
hopefully hopefully things calm down i
think they will i'm very excited we're
going back on the road soon i have some
dates
uh that we'll put out uh hopefully
sooner rather than later but we're
coming to mcgoobies in baltimore we're
going to
comedy connection in providence rhode
island and i'll be uh at seoul joel's
it's an outside thing in pennsylvania
doing the best we can
to get out there and perform but you
know it's harder and harder right now
and um you know we'll be
we'll be having some fun i believe i'm
doing logan paul's podcast again with
whitney
you know whenever she is available to do
that uh podcast she's had some accidents
she walked into a wall and
this is according to her instagram story
which is public she walked in a wall and
she was attacked by dogs
stop helping animals
stop helping stray animals you know
so i don't i don't know what happened
but she was like something happened
where she was attacked
by a dog and her her hands are all
screwed up
i don't get it i don't understand it but
you know and you know what's even
weirder about that somehow a dog
attacked her in a pharmacy
very strange and the dog was wearing a
vest that said dea
so odd these dogs
dogs with jobs i'm of course kidding
um we will see everyone uh
next week ben writes the whole show ben
if you have any problem with anything i
say ben writes the script he hands it to
me i deliver it every single episode
this is the nazi this is the problem you
have a problem with me you have a
problem with him
i'll go i'll go woke i'm just the puppet
he's the one who writes the script if he
writes a different script i will say
different things i want to be on lily
sings show
i want to be on lily sings show imagine
looking at lily sing and going i'm i
can't make it in comedy
imagine looking at lily sing and going i
just can't
figure a way to make it god anything is
i mean there are instagram stars in the
middle of this country
that are just making it because they are
funny on instagram
and they don't even know what comedy is
they don't care they're just [ __ ]
farting in wheelbarrows
and making more money than all these
[ __ ] bitter losers that i [ __ ]
know
be one of those people be one of those
people
you know i don't know what to [ __ ]
tell you
we're coming up with a mistake so it's
gonna be really good
we it might take a year to launch we
don't care but it'll be the best sauce
on the market
if we if we get it perfect if it's not
perfect i won't launch it
or i'll take mcdonald's barbecue sauce
we'll put them in a bottle and then put
our name on it and put it out we don't
know yet but it'll be one of the two
it'll either be the best sauce ever or
you will get sick
you know which is i think a pretty
fitting narrative for
this show and the united states of
america it's either gonna work out
really well
or you will get sick you know or you'll
be sick and it'll work out that's the
real fun
you just go insane and things work it's
it's a fun way to do it do we have a p.o
box there for people to send us things
we will next week next week we have a po
box you can begin sending things to the
show
uh jake angeli uh
will be our guest
next week he'll be the governor of
arizona
oh for sure within 10 years the
country's ending exactly how it's
supposed to
that's what's truly terrifying actually
everything that's happening is
actually should happen
you know what i mean yeah the nuclear
codes are being taken away from trump i
mean it's like
everything there's people with horns at
the capitol there's soccer moms are
being maced in the face
because they believe that they're
protecting kids from tom hanks i mean
no this is everything that should go
down
going down vegas is emptied out
there's nothing to do people are just
gaming it's the
the end of you know the the economy
there's just people just
pulling slots pulling slots wear your
mask
just got the mask on still smoking butts
pulling slots
butts butts out ash the butt put the
mask on
just still pulling slots in vegas
you know i mean it's it's it's truly the
way it all should should go down but i
think
maybe we'll hit a wall with this it will
turn around and things will get uh
things will get you know much brighter
and beautiful
more you know i don't know i mean it
could be i'm very excited about the
spring and the summer
of being you know happy we'll always but
always know this always know this
no matter how happy things get in this
country
we take it our jobs very seriously and
we will always go out and find the
horror
for you and then deliver it to you we
will always go out and find the hell
because there'll be
no shortage of unadulterated
hell pain horror
we'll find it for you i will deliver it
for you
don't worry about it don't don't despair
don't you know what i mean this isn't
going to be this isn't going to turn
into like
jimmy kimmel or stephen colbert were
they like
[Music]
hey everybody i'm on
19 [ __ ] pills to not kill myself and
here's what i have to hey miley
hey everybody hey who's this
it's [ __ ] shit's creek and [ __ ] good
dad leave me from [ __ ] screen you know
what is this quick
it's dead quick they're leaving quick ah
quest practice here who follows me on
instagram
oh really respect to chris pratt i
didn't mean that when i said that
i didn't mean whenever i said i was just
i was
fearful
actually you should put me in a movie
put me in something
put me in one of them you don't want it
to work you gotta you know do
let's throw one to the wolves
something fun let's do something fun
you know i should just dm him because he
follows my instagram i should dm and go
hey man brass tacks are you gonna
produce my film
or not because quite frankly
we should do that to philippe yeah yeah
hey ryan are you gonna produce our movie
can you cut it out please
a lot of celebrities listen to the show
very weird odd but not
not that weird when you think that we're
we're kind of commenting
on things that they they like uh to hear
this you know
but they're in that in that world of
like can't really say anything
can't really say anything ever about
anything so
you know they just they enjoy hearing
you know i guess
this message you wouldn't think they
would
but they do we're about 10 minutes over
the hour here
as you can tell the broadcasting quality
has declined precipitously
but if i were to keep doing the show for
like nine hours
on my 10th hour i would suck as much as
everyone else
like that's what most other people are
putting out by the way
other than like 20 of us that's what
most people are doing okay
i'll be back on the king and the sting
co-hosting with brendan schaub the
greatest comedy team in history
this is what a lot of people are saying
it's not abbott and costello or laurel
and hardy it is me and brandon shaub
on the king in the sting so uh
if you believe that and that is a widely
held belief
so if you believe that as i i don't know
if i believe it but i've just heard it
so frequently that i have to believe it
so
uh very good and then uh
that'll be performing the paramount or
some theater in austin at the end of
january
got tickets i tweeted it out i'll figure
out what it is it's socially distanced
but
it's around there i don't even know i
can find it on your twitter hold on
kenya this will take three hours i hope
no one's got anything to do
would you tweet it out i don't know it's
socially distanced
um let me see is it on my website
i don't think so just say austin or yeah
no i mean it's just just go to my
website
and it's probably not on there either
no yeah it's not on there well whatever
if you could find it it's a problem go
to the paramount austin tim dylan moon
tower comedy thing at austin
go moon tower comedy tim dylan paramount
austin i i'm it's in [ __ ] austin
tower comedy it's tim dillon it's there
paramount theater i knew it yeah january
21st
and the 22nd which is my birthday
january 22nd is my birthday i'm turning
19 years old very excited their
website's not loading but
their website's not loading it's real
folks it's real it's actually happening
late january i'll be in austin texas
there it is
thursday january 21st january 22nd
january 23rd
in austin texas old-ass bio there that's
fine not holding it again it's very
exciting it is a big theater
and it's socially distant so hopefully
we'll have a lot of fun there so grab
tickets to that
if you want to come and see me do you
have anything to plug
are you doing anything you want people
to oh listen to
uh the tim dillon show on youtube
patreon.com the tim dillon show you had
a podcast but you're now done with it
i'm done yeah you're done with it okay
maybe you'll start another one
with uh with you how about i start a
podcast with you no or you're the
co-host
you need more of a following i'm not
doing a crossover unless it's someone
that has a big
following like little huddy
it would be it would be funny one day if
you'd sat here and i just did
you like we had a crossover called the
ben avery show and you produced and i
hosted
yeah and you would just go hello start
just practice do what you would do the
first minute
hello everybody i'm here with i'm here
with my co-host and producer tim dillon
uh we went to vegas this weekend
vegas is a crazy place with crazy people
you know the thing i like about vegas
the valet people at the casinos now are
thankful
that's what you have that's all you have
it's a different it's a 60-second
podcast
but you were copying a lot of what i
said which was disappointing to me
well actually how about this the ben
avery show should be a recap
of the tim dillon show every week we do
three days later
where i talk about what you talking
about no one's doing that
do you see what happens when you let him
speak how how
crazy and off the rails against people
like you
a lot of people like you because they
don't know you this is true
they don't really know you because
they've they've been allowed little
parts of you i've only showed them the
parts of you that i feel will help you
out
yes but they don't know the parts of you
that need not only the
uh leather strap but the buckle whereas
when
you need ben needs to get the buckle
where it's like you just
you ever get hit with a buckle yeah my
dad used to do paddle and belt yeah with
a buckle
well like the i think sometimes i can
hit with the buckle but not across the
face if that's what you mean but on my
ass it's a lot my butt but you need well
you need those beatings
big paddle yeah you need you need more
you need more of that
you need to live in constant fear for
your life and that is when you are at
your best that's what
tina turner michael jackson let's not
lie here
when people stop getting tortured
everything started to suck
billy eilish just had like a lovely
childhood which is why everything's like
i went to i'm happy
that's why that's what happened now
if it was like
billy would be like oh i'm billy i'll
ish i got my ass kicked so i'm good
now
why won't she come on this [ __ ] goon
i'm kidding billy shout out to billy
island she's our sponsor
yeah she sponsors the show we will watch
that doc when it comes out
oh yeah that one that looks like who
took johnny looks scarier than who took
johnny i wish we could play it it's
terrifying i mean is it terrifying it's
like
it's like horror movie music hey hey hey
you're from the suburbs
cut it out this is why people get sick
of white people
because they got to do this goth horror
[ __ ] and it's like you know what you
grew up in the suburbs things aren't
that [ __ ] bad
i got katy perry and dance around with a
with an inflatable dolphin
and get junked up every night please
stop acting like you've been through it
okay you mini witch
act like these [ __ ] they grew up in
the suburbs things aren't that bad
what happened you got sad one day okay
enough stop making these documentaries
like these horror movies where it's like
you don't know how dark and complicated
it all is no
it's not that dark and complicated she
is talented
she has talent and she sings songs for
people that
cut themselves fine no problem with that
not hating on her i think some of her
music is good
but let's not make why are we making a
documentary about her anyway she's
13. secondly why is it the darkest thing
ever where it's like
you'll never understand what it's like
do you not want this would you like all
the theaters and the audiences to go
away
no but it's more complex than that
there's
layers of okay well don't do it
you don't have to do it you want to work
at the
shoe barn
you know i would start in a great line
once about barbra streisand
but was like i just feel so exposed on
stage and so vulnerable and howard stern
was like hey didn't feel that way when
you were hungry
you know this exposure and this
vulnerability is a bit
new but uh how great would it be if the
majority of the billiage documentaries
devoted to talking about me
and the joke i made about her on
instagram she has no idea who i am
if you know billy eilish tell her about
me and tell her how much you like me and
tell her how much you think that
me and her should collab because i could
collab with her on a song easily
totally i could be like i could write a
billy eilish song
yeah right i'll just i'll take the beat
can you find a billy eilish instrumental
royalty free all right
yeah do it do a royalty-free billy
eilish instrumental i can easily write a
billy island song
g free billy eilish type
cats we're just gonna go after the first
one here look at this
easy
in a cloud
i had a nightmare about your breath
[Music]
there were bats and blood
i was sad i left my lunchbox
on the bus my life's a horror show
i'm dark and complex
i'm sad sometimes aren't you
sad too you work at the cell phone store
my brother showed me his genitalia
and someone said i read in the book that
wasn't
okay
but then my agent said shut your mouth
satan's your friend and i said
who is satan and my agent said
we're all satan and i said
that sounds good
so me and my brother and my mama and my
daddy
got an old car i eat vegan food and i
like
my ancient satan
i perform in a stadium
for girls that are very sad
some of them can't keep down the lunch
they ate
that afternoon i don't know why i'm
getting deeper
billy eilish is a black guy oh lord
jesus
i'm billye
i'm
if she released uh an album as like a
blue singer and everyone just had to be
like
i guess it's okay she's like oh lord
the pain i've been through
ladies and gentlemen show uh ladies and
gentlemen thank you we'll see you next
week goodbye
okay we just finished recording we're
coming back on really quickly
uh just to say trump was banned from
twitter you guys all know that right now
uh twitter released a statement saying
it's uh due to the increased incitement
of violence
um so
you know you knew it was coming i think
trump's going on parlor
it'll be interesting what does the news
say we'll cut we'll keep following this
story
we'll keep following the story um
yeah i don't i don't know how i feel
about it i i don't
think that the ban
is appropriate
but i mean you know this is also coming
on the heels of some shenanigans
but i i do think the band's a little
much but i also think that like hey
this is kind of what this guy wanted i
think he wanted it to go down like this
he kind of wanted it to end like this
i think he's getting his wish really
truly i think this is what he wants
all right good luck out there